so can you well if you looked at the
thumbnail and said
then you would be correct but if you
said
and assobu then that would be incorrect
but what's the difference between these
two well that's what we're about to
learn when learning a foreign language
like japanese it's easy to pick up on
and imitate the pronunciation and pitch
accent patterns of words that sound like
words in your own native language for
example if you're a native english
speaker then it's probably pretty easy
for you to pick up on and thus imitate
the accents in the middle of these two
words
to choose
and to eat
because again they both have accents in
the middle and there are many english
words like this such as
banana and computer
banana
computer
now these aren't the exact same accent
patterns because english is a stress
accent language well japanese is a pitch
accent language but the point here is
that again if you're a native english
speaker you can probably tell that these
two words
and
have
some kind of accent in the middle of
them even if you're not listening very
carefully or really concentrating that
said because native english speakers are
used to hearing accents as we've just
seen
it means that we often think an accent
is occurring we often think we're
hearing an accent even when it's not
occurring that is to say because native
english speakers can pick up on the low
high low pattern in to choose
we often unconsciously assume that other
words that kind of look like this one we
assume they're pronounced the same way
we hear
low hi-lo in to choose and then we come
across a word like this to carry or a
word like this to play
and sort of unconsciously think
okay another three syllable or beat
verb that ends with
probably pronounced with the same accent
pattern as in
however this assumption is wrong despite
having a very similar structure and
conjugating the same way as
these two words to carry and to play are
actually pronounced with the
or
accentless pattern as in
and this can actually be quite difficult
for native english speakers to initially
pick up on or reproduce because again
we're so used to saying words with
accents we really want to say
and
so if someone just tells us oh don't say
hakobu but
or oh just say those words flat then
oftentimes that isn't enough to sort of
get the gears turning there's a trick
however that can help a lot with this so
try saying an english word beforehand
with this accentless pattern so
earlier we saw the english words banana
and computer now try saying these
without accents as in
banana
computer
banana
computer
mm-hmm
now that you're used to saying that try
saying the japanese words again so again
banana
computer
so hopefully now you can start to hear
the difference between
and
as well as
and here's a simple rule that you can
remember today to improve your japanese
pronunciation
verbs that end with bl
are typically in this accentless pattern
family and
as well as sakebu to scream and yorokobu
to sort of be filled with joy to be
become happy at something
these three words are actually the
common exceptions to this rule other
common
verbs such as
to call
to fly
as we've seen today to carry
to play as we also saw today but then on
top of that
to learn
to line up
to float and
to tie together
these are all part of this accentless
family there are many other rules like
this that you can learn to immediately
know the pitch accent the accent pattern
of sometimes up to hundreds of words
all by memorizing just one simple rule
and i teach many of these rules in my
patreon course linked below but
if you don't want to dive head first
into paychecks and studies just yet then
start with this boot rule today it's a
great place to start trying to remember
that other than
verbs that end with
are typically going to be accentless and
also try and remember try and become
conscious of the fact that you may be
unconsciously trying to
map the accent patterns of words that
you can pick up on
onto words that have different accent
patterns entirely just this knowledge by
itself will make a big difference in how
you perceive and thus speak japanese
i'll also link some free resources below
that you can use to quickly and easily
look up the pitch accent pattern for any
japanese word okay hope this video was
useful good luck with your japanese
studies and talk to all you guys again
soon